the Stampede happened in a school in
sana's Old City a couple of local
businessmen were handing out money
around ten dollars giving for charity is
a part of the holy month of Ramadan but
this was an unauthorized event and it
turned tragic
booty forces fired into the air to
control the crowd but hit electricity
wires causing an explosion which sent
people running in fear at least 78
people were killed in the Stampede and
dozens were taken to hospital some in a
serious condition
the video footage much of it very
graphic shows bodies lying still on the
ground Blood on the floor and victims
clothes discarded the businessmen have
been arrested
foreign
militia have controlled the capital Sana
since 2014.
for eight years they fought against the
Saudi and western-backed government
forces the Civil War has left tens of
thousands dead in the United Nations
estimates 21 million yemenis are in
urgent need of assistance
there has been some Hope For Peace in
recent weeks a high-level Saudi
delegation visited the capital Sana to
meet with who the officials and a major
prisoner swap has taken place
last night's Stampede is one of the
single worst disasters in Yemen in
recent years
although the deaths aren't directly
linked to the fighting it is because of
the Civil War that so many people are
now so desperate for help
Alistair bunkel Sky News